so we're we certainly have an element of
the Russell Kirk stuff we also have an
element of kind of the radical Roth
party and libertarians and we bring them
together and kind of let them fight it
out and you know make things as lively
as possible I am Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV we are in Las Vegas we're at
Freedom Fest and we're talking with
daniel mccarthy editor-in-chief of the
american conservative thanks for talking
thanks very much you have brought the
American conservative periodical back
from the dead tell us about where the
American Conservative is now and what
are you doing going forward well this
was a magazine got started in 2002 and a
lot of people I think assumed from the
get-go that it would be what they called
paleo conservative back in the 1990's
and Pat Buchanan is you know one of our
contributors he was one of our founders
as were talki theatres Acropolis Scot
McConnell but from the beginning what we
wanted to do was basically present a
conservatism that was more thoughtful
and more sort of eclectic than what you
were getting under george w bush
especially in foreign policy we wanted
to really oppose what we saw as being an
extremely destructive war on terror that
was you know basically undercutting
americans liberties as well as our so
you guys were holding down I don't say
the not even the old right and certainly
not necessarily an isolationist but a
non-interventionist tradition in
American conservativism that's right and
you know this was something that had a
pretty long history both before World
War two but even during the Cold War
there were always sort of patches of
conservatives who wanted to rethink some
of what was going on Robert Nisbet for
example was not a huge fan of some of
the military buildup that we saw yeah
but even people like Russell Kirk right
right yeah I was the first Gulf War back
in the day and whatnot
what what happened to that strain of
conservativism you know and part of it
is World War two happened right and to
be against the American entry into World
War two kind of sidelined a lot of
people but why in the post Cold War era
did the non
vention Aswang if the conservative
movement fall out of favor there was a
lot of mix-up where you know right after
World War two you might have had a
resurgence of the non-interventionist
right
unfortunately because Democrats
generally had control of the government
at the time the developing Republican
party line was that Democrats were
responsible for losing China for losing
various other areas to communism and so
the conservative movement as it was
getting going in the late 40s and early
50s was drawing on that kind of
tradition and even though it was still
somewhat skeptical of certain kinds of
intervention they also wanted to pin the
blame on liberals or Democrats and that
I guess reached its high point when Bob
Dole assured people when he was running
as vice president in 76 that dole Ford
administration wouldn't get us into
those Democrats right what's your unique
role in political debate and discourse
where the Conservatives who are not part
of the movement we're you know sort of
the independent conservatives the
individualist conservatives in some
sense you know so we're we certainly
have an element of the Russell Kirk
stuff we also have an element of kind of
the radical Roth party and libertarians
we bring them together and kind of let
them fight it out and you know make
things as lively as possible where are
the the dividing lines between a kind of
libertarian and conservative alliance I
mean in in the National worldview days
there was a great talk of fusion ISM you
guys are also fusionist of a different
type because you do have libertarian
strains and conservative strains you
know what's the dividing line between
your yeah yeah the deeper kind of
philosophical differences you know
between a Burke for example and a John
Stuart Mill are the ones that are the
most productive to explore because
there's that actually gets you to a lot
of broader questions about what society
is trying to achieve whether it's
whether it should be dynamism for
example as your colleague Virginia
pastoral has described or whether you
know sort of STS Elliott has described
tradition in the individual talent merge
together and reinforce one another I
think that's the interesting debate more
so than just politics about you know gay
rights or abortion or social issues
versus economic issues what do you have
coming up in future issues of the
America
we've got some great stuff the next
issue is going to be looking at both the
10th anniversary of 9/11 and the 20th
anniversary of the collapse of the
Soviet Union we have Andrew bacevich
writing a great piece for that and then
down the line we're going to have John
Mearsheimer and a few other scholars
talking about basically where Israel's
going in the future of US and Israel
relations do you find that you're
picking up more interest among people
who traditionally are aligned on the
left yeah I find we're picking up
interest all across the border but
certainly people like David reef for
example who are on the left but who are
kind of eclectic and not necessarily
part of a movement very interested in
the American service and what's the best
way to subscribe to the American
conservative or to read it I'm sure you
can go to WWE on mag comm and you can
both subscribe there and also read our
online content ok well Daniel McCarthy
thank you very much thanks Nick
for reason TV I'm Nicholas Lee